no my god are we actually live it worked
it's quite a process this is quite the
process to get us to go live people jump
in hopefully every notified try to do uh
three different ones for you guys mm-hmm
let's wait a little bit only we had
someone on board there we go we got
fourteen eyes on us I'm just gonna post
on the community page going had to
restart it sorry about that guys I don't
know why I wasn't going live or was
being kind of weird but how you guys
doing well sixty people in here already
and I did see a super check coming from
when we were setting up for a man named
Brian some I wanna say thank you
probably weren't even here yet and
you're a super chatting us away yeah
you're beautiful son of a [ __ ] I just
got post one thing on the community cage
right now on YouTube how's it going in
Italy it's Greg's favorite country yes
it is John yes it is hey McHale how's it
going guys Charlotte della yeah you know
this black panther beanie I rarely wear
it because it likes suctions on to my
head it kind of cuts off circulation so
but you know Black Panther wants so many
awards that I wasn't expecting it to win
but dudes look we got an appointment to
make at we gotta wrap this up no later
than 12:35 p.m. which is in 30 eight
minutes from now but I wanted to talk
about this you know and I'll say I want
to start off with this we were at an
Oscars party and there was an Oscars
pool five bucks to play I won that's
right 18 out of 24 guessed correctly I'm
the man i won $25 and it was well worth
it covered the pizza that I contributed
to the party so I feel pretty good right
now and the biggest one thanks Olivia of
the biggest one that I didn't I thought
I was gonna lose when I saw Black
Panther was winning because I never
voted for Black Panther but at that
point I was like I
happy if I lose if Black Panthers gonna
be winning this much because that was
really cool that Black Panther was
winning yeah yeah I was really happy for
them you know historical times
historical landmark times John would you
think of the Oscars I thought it was
pretty fun I mean I come into the Oscars
almost every year now with pretty low
expectations but I liked not having the
hosts I thought there were some fun
speeches and you know stands a couple
Awards a thousand fine with a lot of
stuff tonight Apple John will shave his
head at six hundred twenty five thousand
subscribers right Harry Potter love you
too Ron okay yeah I actually was so
surprised by because there's all this
fiasco leading up to the Oscars and I
got to tell you guys I surprisingly
really enjoyed the Oscars I don't know
if so because when I'm participating in
a pool I'm more invested in what's going
on yeah but I feel like the the
situations with the host and everything
has always been kind of a weird energy
for the show because they're trying to
make it appeal to all kinds of audiences
and the young demographic and it has
like this comedy infused and then you
have like prestiged and it feels like
pretentious at times and I feel like
actually cutting out the hosts allowing
the presenters to just be funny as
you're already because usually you have
a host and presenters and you just allow
the presenters to be funny or you know
whatever do their job I felt like the
Oscars actually knew what it was about
this time as opposed to the previous
year's were like what are you guys
trying to do exactly they do whenever
Tyrell spits yeah this is boring and for
me I personally had it I thought like if
flew by I didn't fly by but it went
faster than a century and I thought
there were some really cool standout
moments and you know I I would never
want the Oscars to turn I feel like
they've to make the Oscars just pure
entertainment you got it like really
treat it like a competition but then
again that would I just don't feel like
that be now make it worse hoarders
dating but it would make it worse for
everyone to bring out something ugly I
think yeah yeah yeah don't worry we're
gonna talk about a few things on the
agenda that I have here of what I want
touch on of course Spike Lee the Bradley
Cooper Lady Gaga performance Olivia
Colman Black Panther Bohemian Rhapsody
Xand you're my tone they're the Olivia
Colman speech and the Hennessy XO Ridley
Scott seven worlds short that ran the
one-minute cut during the broadcast
yes commercial ever you guys have to go
check it out those those that's the best
Hennessy you'll ever have yeah the best
commercial ever put together there's a
four-minute cut of it on YouTube just
saying in case just watch it after this
live stream not during this life just
saying later
so we already touched on the host okay I
want to start off with talking about
that while we got because we always have
the most people here at the beginning
yeah that performance of Bradley Cooper
and Lady Gaga hahaha well the way they
just went right into it with no segue
was so cool I don't know if you guys
have seen it the frigid when Bradley
Cooper went to one of Lady Gaga's
concerts and perform there but they were
even more intimate there and I think
it's cuz Bradley Cooper's wife wasn't
around they're so damn intimate and when
they perform I guess it gets confusing I
was talking about this with my
girlfriend on the way back last night of
why it's kind of confusing when you
watch their performance really because
they're not acting there and they're not
doing a scene from a stars born there
they're just Bradley Cooper Lady Gaga
does not losing eye contact and and Lady
Gaga is so is so passionate every time I
see him in the interview she's just
she's just a feeler that person you know
she's always feeling but when she
performs a Bradley Cooper who's like her
better days like you said he wasn't
gonna resurrect the character or
anything like that for this performance
but they certainly resurrected that
moment because like the sparks flying
and also just amplified by its big
Hollywood okay you know like I see oh
it's Bradley Cooper not marios he's just
dating that victorious either way he's
with someone
it's kind of [ __ ] weird thanks to
Roger a sweet guy for doing that buddy I
love you yeah no because in that
specific performance I was taken aback
by this is there like no is something
boy like rather Cooper's like smiling at
me like he's kind of friendzone treating
her a little bit he's kind of doing that
thing was like I want her to want to
[ __ ] me
but I'm not going to [ __ ] but but then
lady gaga's likes [ __ ] to it too in
front of everyone you in front of your
date tonight have sex on top of this
piano that was the most talked about up
to me that was like the most talked
about thing that was happened at the
Oscars that night and that's what
stopped everybody in their tracks and I
think even the people who just like hate
everything about the Oscars are like Tim
though shallow man I saw I saw it memes
going around of like some get somebody
who looks at you the way Bradley Cooper
looks at not his girl so soon when they
go up on stage he just put their hands
in front of his girl and then they just
walk up I was easily the sexiest moment
of the night it was there yeah new
panties all around and okay well so we
got on the agenda that really stood out
the Spike Lee winning Spike Lee I mean
you gotta count on Spike Lee for given
the political speech you know that's one
thing with the Oscars I didn't think
about it the Oscar host you usually get
a lot of political stuff which tends to
be this like we divide I don't know why
it's Hollywood keep it at all yeah but
Spike Lee you can count on it especially
what his movie is so much in tune with
what his speech was actually about it so
you know that makes sense but the big
part of that that was so excited you
literally can see two different ruined
when brie Larson Sam Jackson were on
stage you could see Sam Jackson when he
read for was a original screenplay for a
green book who's like
yeah I didn't realize until the best
pitcher came up that those two like
black Klansmen and greenbook were the
things kind of in most competition
around each other and most because in
terms of subject matter and then if you
were to boil down to the basic of the
basics of racism's wrong like the most
basic form of that you got the super
Hollywood version and then you got the
one that really speaks with a lot of
potency the black Klansmen version of an
authentic voice to it as well these is
more on the pleasant side you can take
your grandparents to see it and all kind
of be happy that you know folks can get
a lot yeah yeah definitely or yeah you
can go with kind of the heavier more
historical I mean they're both
historical but black Klansmen seems to
have much more of a wait about I don't
know if I won for that anyway a black
Klansmen hey Jana thanks thank you so
much uh keep finding that need doc
Jenna's one of our patrons the sweet
girl she put out her we wouldn't have
watched that Kingsman the Golden Circle
trailer years ago no bad tell her thanks
Jenna you're so sweet go look at your
new job by the way
but okay yeah that when and then once
when Spike Lee won and he went up and
wrapped it likes around Sam Jackson was
one of the best moments of them like
there was some real highlight moments
for me I I surprisingly enjoyed this and
I thought I was just gonna be bored out
of my mind watching it there was some
actual energy in that room and this was
the other first Oscars in a while I was
like yeah I can jot down a list of my
favorite moments sure that was easy to
know and one greenbook one everyone in
the room was like what as I thought I
thought Alfonso Cuaron had prepared for
speeches yet half wanted Alfonso to just
go up there and repeat the same speech
over and over again you heard the first
three parts so I'm gonna recite them
again I wanna whole speech start looking
around the room just for people to think
I want you the usher back there thanks
for keeping order thanks - uh thanks -
they sinks to my that guy the last
weight rack guys who brought me this
champagne I think my uber driver
for bringing me to my little burr -
that's that's high let's that's it man
I thought Romo was gonna win best
picture I did too I have Romo down for a
Best Director Best Cinematography best
for my my father we're gonna do the
ultimate and then do you know best
pitcher for Romo and instead of got
green book and green book is a movie I
really enjoyed I didn't that's a fun
movie to watch yeah with the good
worthwhile message if it feels like a
pg-13 Disney movie that's saying racism
is wrong the whole time yeah it's like a
family movie with a slight amount of
edge when the racism cuts is so slight
yeah and the thing though is like that
my personal feelings for the movie aside
all the controversy behind it and all
the things of what people find
problematic with it I also agree with
that as well though it's like I can look
at that movie and go yeah it's a fun
movie it's about white man being saved
you know making another one of those I
believe white Savior films and then you
have this character who apparently the
family members for surely we didn't
consult us about this story and then a
lot of it was fictionalized in a they
they turned his story into something
where it's about another white Savior
version which is a very Hollywood
version to approach racism and and I do
you think I do think that black clansmen
is overall a much better movie and more
deserving when it's going for something
harder it's more confrontational and
it's it's doing something a bit wider
than and it has it has the same message
it has more of the it has similar
messages to a green book is essentially
implying but it actually does it in a
way that sort of haunts you in a
direction of its racism is scary and you
shouldn't be racist it also has a
sufficient amount of you know Spike
Lee's signature rhythm and stuff like
that so it is also entertaining film
like Green Book is but it's entertaining
it's got a certain personality and fun
about parts of it you know
well the
and I heard that Spike Lee there's a lot
of reports going around though when you
know if you every time you cut the Spike
Lee you you can see what his honest
reaction is on anything that's going on
now you like they have a camera
specifically dedicated to him every year
you know like they don't keep isn't
appropriately laugh or politely laugh
when he doesn't feel like laughing if
someone's making a joke and he doesn't
find it funny
he's not gonna laugh you know he's gonna
be himself he let off F words in his
speech that they had to give a bleep
death start the guys that clock so when
I heard the reports that Woodhouse's
responded and then you hear some of the
things he said you know at the after the
awards were done in terms of greenbook
winning he had a thing about feeling
like he was he had like what the best
seats in the game house and then
suddenly the I forgot how that quote
goes all right then about how the ref
made the bad call yeah but this is
similar to what happened with him when
he lost to do the right thing and there
was a film driving miss daisy'
which is kind of similar to Green Book
and so I heard the reports that he got
up he walked to the back then he came in
and when the the acceptance speech was
going on and his back was turned to a
fairly brother named Peter family yeah
his back was turned him during the whole
speech and I was very surprised hearing
it before as I was hearing it I was
thinking man Twitter's gonna have a
story about this he almost as much as
they would have been booking me arrested
what if Peter Farrelly was like giving
all this praise to Viggo Mortensen it
was kind of just throwing more as videos
great in the movie but it kind of does
just throw more fuel to the fire when
you're like Marshall Lee just won the
Supporting Actor honor this movie this
little story should have been more about
Marshall Ollie to begin with and this is
his like this the real great journeys
with him the guy who like actually had
to be in so many uncomfortable positions
and been forced to suffer at times
throughout this journey was done surely
less it see would seem certainly then
Nick fella longer yeah like he's the guy
who's making it safer for him to travel
you know so granted I didn't know if
I didn't know if Peter Farrelly was
specifically ripped I didn't know if
Peter Farrelly was specifically
referencing you know like oh he's gonna
get this project off the ground until
Vigo signed on or I didn't know if
that's where he was going with that
yeah but it just seemed like he was
saying Vigo this whole thing is you man
it sounds like you that's how he's
saying it I don't know if there's more
context I don't know what the
pre-production to this movie was but
that's just how I've interpreted to me
let me tell you about another white guy
who made all this possible
just takes me right back to that
Wonder Woman pitch meeting about like
there's got to be more diversity in
Hollywood and it starts with yeah that
was a crazy moment right there also uh
yeah black panther it's several wins I
was so happy for it yeah matter of fact
it was getting to the point where I was
like dude if this was the best picture
is on my favorite film of the year [ __ ]
yeah that'd be great
you know it's be unexpected yeah as
opposed to just a nomination I thought
this was gonna be as it was shaping out
I thought it was turning into what would
what Mad Max fury road in that year yeah
winning so many Oscars did it win as
many as Mad Max was still this is easily
the most awards for I don't I can you
guys let us know in the comments here in
the live stream was the MCU one other
Oscars before I feel like maybe once
we've got a lot of fills at least one
would have won some kind of visual
effects awards or smait be sound of some
kind or you know a technical award or
something but I thought that was really
cool for Black Panther especially
because it was like costumes and design
for a lot of it and that is stuff that
was pretty just overwhelming for some
people to see on screen you know I
imagine you know it's it's all very
rooted in culture and so like to see it
awarded for that I thought was really
cool because that's like even though you
could say oh you know they're kind of
humoring the big blockbuster superhero
movie by giving them more technical
awards like I think those are awards it
actually really earns you know and and
moved a lot of people with those
elements of the film but not makeup know
why nominated for makeup why use all
five of your slots yeah
you know I've heard that megohm only has
three for some reason why I don't know
it only has three that's weird but if
Black Panthers gonna get production
designed costume designs to make up
having Middle East deserves a nomination
for makeup yeah that's crazy these kind
of goes hand it's like if Bohemian
Rhapsody because I even though that
wasn't my pick I'm gonna go into my
bohemian stuff later because in our own
[ __ ] loves that movie so wait for
people like we're Bohemian when I won
its first sound award good because I did
vote for that I was also like okay well
now stuff like no.1 the other one right
is this videos hand in hand please same
thing with makeup when it comes to
production design I get that vice one
because you know there was like an upset
with the visual effects for infinity war
not winning and losing the first man the
thing though is is I've heard from both
visual effects artists and makeup artist
that when you're trying to replicate
something that is very realistic
something that you can actually see in
real life or have seen and tell it like
something that's real
for example the Vice makeup is very
realistic or the first man you have to
replicate something that a lot of people
have seen footage of and you have to
make that very realistic so that is
actually harder to do I've heard that a
lot of people say that because of the
Association we have it's easier to tell
it's fake as opposed to something that's
so fantastical you can kind of like have
a lot more wiggle room way you can add
to it and change with it to make it look
or we don't
your suspension of disbelief is totally
different and I really was happy to see
first man walk away with something like
that cuz like I actually put infinity
war on my ballot because I thought they
would because they're good effects in
that movie but first man like is
transported with those launch sequences
and their moon sequences like I am
really happy for them yeah I voted for
first mass after they won yeah yeah add
into that 18 tally I only got 12 thanks
Janet can't wait friend game as well a
annoying rants are we gonna talk more
are they also sack with taking a little
sidestep here
thanks for it freaks with super chat
there buddy hey guys love
channel personally I think blinds fine
did a better job attacking similar
things green book but it was I hope you
guys watched my last episode of parents
last week on movie fights
spoiler alert did not win but I really
do hope you guys go watch at least the
first round because that's where I talk
about why I think blind spotting should
have been nominated and arguably should
have won Best Picture and yeah I highly
agree I think it does a better job than
blind spotting and I think last night
was a better job than black clansmen
angry but good
I would definitely highly recommend you
guys go watch that thanks to know her
answer for bringing that up
also ok what was next on the next on the
agenda here John oh snaps well we're
waiting to get into Bohemian do we want
to talk about a couple of the highlights
like maybe Olivia Colman or some oh yeah
yeah Livia Coleman dude that was that
was such a standout speech right there
that was the one that just touched my
heart that was the one that made me the
happiest cuz I could you could just tell
she didn't expect that and it was so
natural and so off-the-cuff and that is
like the magic of the Oscars to me is
when somebody's like oh damn I just
gotta wing it I haven't seen the
favorite and the thing is a lot of
people the favorites one of those movies
where I feel like I have to watch it
right
it was Olivia Colman speech that made me
go now I want you to watch this movie
and it's weird how she's not winning the
wind is a promotion in and of itself but
she's not really talking about the
character or anything like that but
there's just something about her
enthusiasm and her love and that the the
underdog wins like that where people are
at least prepared for the fact that are
gonna win are it's the most rewarding
head of them all and her speech is so
self-aware yeah completely genuine or it
was also like kind of fun a little bit
unwieldy like it's the best kind of
Oscar speech to me because you could
tell like this is not planned it's a
little bit awkward but but in the best
way yeah oh it's so funny the whole joke
about her husband he's gonna cry I'm not
gonna cry and they come back and or
she's just like Lady gaga I feel like
you're about sage amongst all these
people you admire I imagine there's a
moat we were like oh my god people I
watch it follow her everywhere here like
this is insane you yeah that was that
was a delight right there and I'm happy
for her because I see the trailers and
she's the least advertised in that yeah
she is you know it's all the pushing
Emma Stone and Rachel vice because of
the famous ones but Olivia Colman it's
cool that she won the Oscar and now I
know I feel like more people will watch
it because of her yeah well and and the
thing is from hearing so many other
people's reviews of the movie that she
is usually the standout people point now
like yeah they're like oh the whole cast
is great for various reasons but Olivia
Colman was my favorite absolutely the
favorite okay okay oh hey hey we got a
new new Bob over here you may love this
channel but watch this is 10,000 subs
this is my first lie thirsting reals
I've seen keep doing what we did dude 10
2000 subs iam that was 504 than 10,000
subsequently I remember that moving in
that shitty ass [ __ ] apartment in
Highland Park would the worst landlord
you could ever ask for I hope he's
watching oh he loves his chest bastard
hey you so sad this is you thanks for
being us two cent thousand new bobbin
MPE 94 says at least Green book is the
best film called green book crash wasn't
even the best crash that's nice
you know what you're right Green Bay
deserve the win that honor its own
namesake okay is there any other things
we're missing I want to talk about
Bohemian Rhapsody
let's do I want to talk about booking or
everyone leaves leaves alive so leave a
live stream now if you're if you can't
handle criticism towards Bohemian
Rhapsody
I see you McHale thanks for jumping in
here dude buddy
okay so we're gonna begin the sound
editing and sound mixing to me as much
as when I watch a quiet place and I go
there be sound here there were totally
down here I still think with that movie
being sound as one of the stars of one
of the most distinct and moving parts of
that and with sound design and sound
editing as one of the most under
recognized positions as and also one of
the most important elements to make any
film work unbelievable and transport you
there it's the key element of modern
cinema like literally the fact that a
quiet place didn't win it's kind of
ridiculous to me especially when I when
I think of Bohemian Rhapsody I'm like
what do you mean like the ultimate DJ
effects artists mixing all the other
thing is that at least one of those
categories also had a star is born in it
and a stars born does all the things
Bohemian Rhapsody does but in a more
natural way with real music real live
performance performance like
demonstrates live rock band music in a
more fluid more finessed way than that
movie does with yet the original music
and actually at least some onset
performances and stuff so I'm like if
you're gonna give it to in Bohemian
[ __ ] a star is born did more than that
movie that was one of the movies that I
watched and I was like the editing and
this is weird like what's that like yeah
weird is not flowing well I don't I just
did not get it I think it's just I feel
like I'll rap to the awards it's like we
love Queen Adam Lambert and the rammy
Malick I'm not gonna city look here's
the thing
I don't not gonna say I think he did a
bad job cuz I don't think he did a bad
job it's so apparent he gave it his all
and everyone loves him so much in that
role I just don't love him as much in
that movie as much as everyone else does
you know we like that cliche of that
Oscar winning speech moment you know
like whenever they have that same scene
you're like oh that's the Oscar winning
scene moment you know I don't
know about that for Remy Malick
specifically for every other category in
them in that every actor of that
category I could think of scenes and
whenever people tell me about like
Bohemian Rhapsody a lot of people talk
about the Live Aid performance and I'm
sure you guys would jump in and tell me
some stuff no MP 94 but I did not ignore
your super chat we totally talked about
greenbook being that you were just
weren't listening crash wasn't even the
best crash I said to deserve someone
because of that I totally read in Alice
listen up man so thank you so so Raimi
Ramy whatever alright it's like the Live
Aid sequence and all that stuff like I
when I when I look at Bradley Cooper in
a star is born I can think of several
scenes from like that would one of the
scenes is the scenes they play when they
when they said he thought faded and what
like so many scenes in that movie
they're just like those are powerhouse
scenes yeah but for some reason Raimi
Malick lip singing maybe her Ave city is
so much more powerful Hey yeah I didn't
think that clip supported him at all cuz
he's not actually singing and he's not
actually playing that piano yeah which
which I guess you know in a weird ironic
way kind of encapsulates how at least
some people feel about that movie is it
is just you know a lip-sync
impersonation yeah somebody and you know
not to take away like the the
performance elements I do think he did a
great job on those but yeah just for an
all-around performance for a movie that
relies so much on music and live
performance and stuff I feel like his
performance is bolstered by so many
other things that yeah I don't know I
don't know I've seen like a lot of you
see I think it's fair to actually make
this judgment because of how
fictionalized Bohemian Rhapsody is of
yeah I've watched I watched like a lot
of interviews of would like those
long-ass interviews with Freddie Mercury
and I just don't see right I don't see
it I see I see Freddie Mercury when he's
doing the lip singing part yeah that's
when I see it like the live a cuz he's
got the bought the movement down and
everything and the facial expression one
of the dialogue scenes I'm like he seems
like so much more like flam oh yeah yeah
that's another one of those details were
after seeing the movie everyone's like
you know Freddie it seemed like he was
actually like a bit more calm a bit more
reserved time and then you know
performing would bring it out of him and
stuff and I'm sure that he had moments
like in the movie but yeah the whole
time he's kind of like large and in
charge
feels like look I'll say that he carries
that movie but I just didn't think that
it was a more powerful performance than
a lot of the other Morgan's yeah he just
didn't carry it enough for me to push it
past so many other films and perform it
see I voted for him I knew you was going
to win oh honey one I was like wouldn't
have been my personal pick I would have
been happy to lose to that one because
I'm like how come Bradley Cooper's
performance is nowhere near as
acknowledged on the same level I know
because he's I'm like he does everything
but more and it's also not got the weird
albatross of like changes of history
that seem disingenuous to hamper the
dramatic effect of the movie like yeah
there's so much struggle in that
character that he draws and there are so
many different dimensions and he learned
to sing and play guitar yeah you know so
I I'm just kind of taken aback what is
so much of the performance of Freddie
Mercury in that is a lip-sync and so you
can't hear the Trent and I part of
acting is more than just dialogue and
voice whatever but so much of the
emotion you can see it in their live
performance which Bradley could relay to
Gaga so much of the emotion is through
their singing in there and you don't get
that with Freddie Mercury and Bohemian
Rhapsody because it's a little sing yeah
I mean you get you get the effect of
Queen basically yeah I don't know how
much does Queen affect you and that's
and a lot of people felt like Christian
Bale should have won for that scenic
alright here I hear one and that's for
that movie I mean I haven't seen Vice
yet but that's one of those things where
everyone's like movies alright but
Christian Bale is incredible yeah so I
feel like maybe he didn't win just
because I mean hey everybody loves
Bohemian Rhapsody Rami Malek and all
that but also like we've seen him
immerse this way before so maybe people
are less impressed now yeah that's true
and he
the Golden Globe so you can be like oh
you know consolation anyway guys um yeah
man Cooper really didn't win much I
think it's just because a star is born
it's its fourth time around I thought
that like going against it just because
that even though I don't agree with that
criticism each year it becomes more
clear to me that like those kinds of
perceptions like as the fourth star is
born or like everyone loves Bohemian
Rhapsody like those things really do
seem like they figure in they say like
the Oscar wins are off of the votes but
I'm like I just it doesn't make sense
when I watch this ever it's every
ceremony I'm like oh but also though how
is everybody calculating their vote what
is everybody's you know reason for
voting a certain way on a certain
category did somebody go oh I voted it
for you know I voted for Alfonzo here
because I think that most people are
gonna vote for this guy or whatever you
know there's so many ways to handicap it
too anyway
yeah I think the Oscar should continue
with no host I actually preferred that
yeah I feel like speeds to show up and
in the show it seems like it knows what
it's really about then you get more
variety and Ryan Terry Henry's also less
I think also in terms of like a comedic
stamp book as the the host always funny
people it I feel like it allows for the
presenters to feel more comfortable to
make jokes yeah and be funny because
there's none of that pressure to match
the host her yeah where am I getting
made fun of by the host you know yeah
bit and it allows for the people we're
not as used to being funny or eccentric
- yeah it seemed like there was more
appropriate time for their speeches to
go on totally so yeah yeah I liked it
anyway guys that we're gonna wrap this
up in like a couple minutes literally
got to we have no choice Oh in Spyder
versus when we reverse it's right to the
spider-verse winning that we all know
that wasn't very well worth it that was
one we're lucky we all want this happen
it should happen yeah it did happen and
thank goodness that Phil Lord and Chris
Miller directed that movie and all that
it could be the directors definitely
it's their movie a hundred percent
nobody else I said that in my review
that it's gonna get to that point like
9-mer before Christmas or everyone
thinks those guys directed it and we
were we we were at an event at an event
where they've they presented something
about Phil Lauren
Chris Miller and the guy on the
microphone talker this whole craft and
director Lester in today one of them
corroded you know what the whole crowd
did I didn't hear anyone going that's
not true because other three people
credit yeah I know they did this we're
making fun yeah yeah so many people
think they did this alright guys well
hey thanks for tuning into our live
stream we got to talk to our people who
do the live streams who know how to you
know like in terms of having a better
camera setup for it we don't understand
any of those plugins anything you've
ever seen updated on this channel in
terms of quality from sketches so even
though the reactions when I would do
them in the beginning with I used to
them off a laptop and upgrading at all
it's all things that we just figure out
on our own so the we have to figure out
how to do the upgrades for the live
stream camera qualities but we will be
doing that cuz we have been enjoying
doing them it's fun interacting with you
guys I'm getting to be here so really
appreciate where you just got here some
of y'all but we got [ __ ] to handle we
got shoot videos for patreon got some
edits to do for patreon some videos to
finish for the rest of the week so thank
you guys and we will be at the sroa
free-for-all so ever so we're out here
for the hundred eighty something people
watching we will be at the Spandau free
for all let Christian know that we've
said that because he doesn't think we
promote yeah all right thank you mate
patriarchy but it's the cheats we've
looked at everyone you know the little
things to us and we are the cheapest so
yeah I'm not going to go ahead say we
have only like everyone else who does
similar stuff I'm worth the cheapest of
them all so hello I'm not saying yes to
that thank you guys for everything much
love